so yeah explain explain this to me what
do you what exactly do you mean so he
calls out dana for paying the fighters
12k a fight and he's like you need to
raise it to 50 and you need to give them
health care a lot of left people on
twitter lost their noodles because it
was a it was a moral conflict inside
it's like it's jake paul
but he's really pushing for labor rights
here god god damn it he's right
[Music]
dana responded to him it's like this
long video
play it yeah play it yeah play it i need
to see it you said i do cocaine
that's like the
that's what you're gonna take away from
this video jake you never respond to
that okay i saw a clip of this before
but publicly stated that i use cocaine i
do not
so i told you you could randomly cocaine
test me for the next 10 years
i believe that you're a cheater
i'm sorry
cocaine test me
[Laughter]
you can't test me for the others
but you can test me for a cocaine
you want a coke you can find a cocaine
test if you can even find a test that
only does cocaine
you can use it because that's the only
thing you can test me for
okay
like this guy runs a billion dollar
company
that drug tested employees as part of
the [ __ ] work
says
it's so stupid but it's so funny i
honestly want to know if that exists
yeah you can just only for that
what would they do
what would they do they'd like someone
would come up and smell your nose that's
what they do
they put their nose up to your nosing
and smell yeah
no this guy's been doing coke no you
know what they do they um
they have like uh
like some type of like substance that's
like like really dry and they just rub
it on your nostrils to see if you get
irritated
you know just to see if yeah it dude
you know like no no no they no no it's
they
they make out with them and see if their
mouth goes numb oh yeah there you go
there you go there it is yeah bingo
it's some dude
some dude in a like a you know scrubs
he's like all right dude we got it you
said you said any any time for the next
10 years
we can cocaine test you this is what a
cocaine test is so sorry i gotta we
gotta smooch
[ __ ] her up dude we're french kissing
i was just thinking of the cocaine test
some guy walks by with like a small
mirror and a credit card and he just
taps it just like out of earshot and if
you like if you perk up it's like that
got him
that's like a you jingle keys neck like
near him yeah got him someone goes
within 10 feet of him and jingle some
keys what's up
yeah we going yeah yeah that's all you
say oh right now oh [ __ ]
what do you mean right now what are we
doing right now
oh you i thought we were going to the
gym
you're going to drive me somewhere to
smooth it to jamba juice
to smoothie juice
smoothie juice cocaine testimony
[Laughter]
all right all right let dana finish the
dana
it's a scantron it's a scantron test
cocaine test
there are three girls in the bathroom
and you only have two lines how do you
split them up
i don't know i don't know
i don't do cocaine so i don't know this
it's a
that's the written portion yes
it's gotta write a little paragraph
two two girls nostrils are traveling at
different speeds along the same line
how long until their noses meet
i don't know but they're wasting my blow
correct
you've tested positive for cocaine
i don't know if these [ __ ] are
wasting my blow
ding ding ding you've tested positive oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right all right now let dana finish
whatever i want
to randomly steroid test you for the
next two years
and that thing that you came out with
today
nobody on earth thinks that you really
wrote that you're too stupid and for
those of you that don't know if you've
ever watched one of his fights and you
see when they do the stare down the guy
that's standing in the middle with the
warlock nose and the big warlock ward on
his face
apparently that's his manager and that
guy used to be an accountant for me
and
let's just say this he no longer works
for me
and i think he's a scumbag
but
if you two think that you can do it
better than we do uh you know
we're doing this whole thing wrong you
could treat the fighters better than we
do knock yourself out go start your own
business it's easy to do goes to get the
warlock on it the warlock could get it
started for you
what you and the warlock should be
focused on is your business
you're tanking you can't sell
pay-per-views
you know no yeah you're calling out
jorge masvidal because he's a
pay-per-view superstar
nate diaz
conor mcgregor mike tyson
these are all superstars
you're not you can't sell pay-per-view
so
you do whatever the hell you want to do
i'm ready to roll buddy i don't use
cocaine do you use steroids
let's do this jake
that was good that was good yeah it was
a good uh
honestly
a pretty great retort
yeah then yes people kind of picked it
apart
um well i mean he kind of
weaved in and out of his point you know
yeah kind of got lost in the wart thing
and the accountant thing and
you know it's kind of all over the place
but i'd stay i'd say pretty solid ending
yeah
uh
i love how people in the replies were
saying
another typical ad hominem reply from
dana white
like bro
you're gonna walk up to [ __ ] you
master tomato and be like don't make fun
of me that's ad hominem
the [ __ ] up dude
master tomato is that what you just
called that's what i call him yeah
he's cause like he's like the final
tomato you know yeah i like that
uh
he he says that jake's using steroids
but there's no way that
dana's not also using steroids yeah
yeah but you know
that's not part of the cocaine test
yeah
[ __ ]
jake
so jake in his reply his reply is
actually funny uh and i know it sucks to
admit but it's funny and he like
i it's like three minutes long so i'm
just gonna you know paraphrase it but in
between all of jake's statements
he just
uses the like a sliver of dana saying i
use cocaine and it has this awful
like cocaine pant like png pinned to his
nostril
he'll be like dana you don't pay your
fighters enough i use cocaine
dude he goes as far as to say he's like
me on steroids look at me i'm a fat [ __ ]
and he stands up and he grabs his
stomach he's like look at me and he's
smacking his stomach he's like i'm fat
as [ __ ]
jake said that yeah
and then he's like he's funny he's like
come stereo test me i don't care and
then you know i use cocaine
and then here's the funniest best part
is when jake talks about
like fighter pay
he goes dana you are one of the most
selfish capitalistic [ __ ]
and i went whoa
whoa
big words for jake ball bro
damn
i just thought it was funny he's calling
him like a capitalistic [ __ ]
when he just rinsed everyone
turns capitalistic even a word it's just
capitalists isn't it
could something be capitalistic i think
so i don't think so i don't think that's
a word capitalistic it is a word god
[ __ ] damn it yeah man i'm telling you
supporting are based on the principles
of capitalism
it it it's a little bit hypocritical of
him
i know that's someone else capitalists
capitalistic
is it not yeah i thought that was kind
of funny but you know he that's pretty
good on his fight card you know these
guys selling this guy's selling
like potentially set up fights for 50
bucks a pop
hey but he pays those fighters well
though
yeah
okay
is there anything more [ __ ]
capitalist than pay-per-view
um
[Music]
yeah
the whole thing is based on promotion
and sales yeah and convincing people to
watch and hype and there's
nothing more capitalist than that yeah
that was that was the only part where i
was like
that's a bit of a if jake left that out
you know
10 out of 10 reply
you